来做一个过来人和他分享一些普通人的约钱到底该怎么约钱
因为我们普通人没有人告诉你该怎么做
跟我讲和他分享一些我个人的一些经验
我们很多人都认为我通过努力提升认刺通过努力
我可能我的生活就会发生变化
但是我变化其实很小的
真正的变化是来自于三个关系要素的
首先第一个呢是规则
第二个呢是
资源第三个是人资
规则就听什么呢规则就听你能不能入场
你能不能玩这个游戏你能分多大的单高
其实我们很多人
其实根本感受不到规则存在
为什么呢因为他记不参与规则
同时其实也不受规则的舒服
因为本身他并不去
规则吧
反而是终成
终监这一层
他会抱怨规则所以你会发现很多分情其实都是
那有些人他是想说规则的红密的
所以规则决定了什么人入场
决定了你分多大的单高对吧所以你能看到很多人其实在体制内
你说他认识高吗他认识也不高
但他生活他还挺舒服的
对吧
第二个呢
就叫做资源资源决定了
你的试错的成本
你有多少
把我这个机会的这个
能把我说机会吧或者是你的那个刚点
你我都跟他刚点这么的仇用就来
第三个也的话呢其实就是认识认识认识其实决定的是当这个试会发生变化的时候
你
是否能够睡的或者是你能把我做到的机会
那有些人的话呢
很多时候就是你
认识很搞但是没资源
就会变成
知道分子
就是我们说的高认识求认
对吧那有些人的话呢他可能有资源
但是认识不够
对吧
他可能就会一次错误的决策就会提出这个圈刺
比如说一些
反而
不是所有的反而就是
一些反而来或者是有一些人通过婚姻呢通过别的方式啊进入了那个隐藏
但其实
没有的
你认识不够
那么我们到底该怎么变化呢我给大家去三个
变化他的意思了首先第一个如果你的认识够但是没资源怎么办
你要学会用你的认识变形
对吧比如说用你的认识
去建立一些产品
可能是资源的产品啊可能是资源啊可能是自媒体啊
对媒体啊通过提升自己的
这样的
一个争度
或者是个级累来获得的
来获得资源
这是
我自己就是这样的一个例子
变像说自己是个认识不要高的人
好像也是
第二类的话呢就是
你可能是有资源但是你认识之后怎么办
这个时候就要去上课
就是要去上课
就是要去连接人
就是垮记
有的时候就需要通过
您有的东西就换去
你没有的东西对啊比如说
最近有一个大模型就跑得挺快的
其实就是用您有的东西来换去没有的东西了对
那很多人说
我啥都没有怎么办
啥都没有的时候
记住你有的你就要学会利用规则
利用规则
或者是找到规则变化的那个点
比如说是在的红明
这科技来的时候有些规则说发生在边的
这个时候你其实是一个很好的机会
但是我们大部分很难抓到这个机会的为什么因为他们就习惯了
听话
我印象
床业者,床业者一定是利用规则的东西
或者是在规则变化的时候
快速的行动
否则化其实你是很难坐下的
好吧就在身
这个位
就是你的成功一点有什么首先第一个是你的规则
你能不能入场
第2个部分呢,取久音的次元
你有多少失错的机会
你有多少失错的机会,你利用多大的尴尬
能把我机会,第三个都是你的认识
就是决定你是不是能够
稍用
你的高度取久音于第三次里面
所以第一个点